hallo herr staatenwelt wir möchten heute
ganz leckere marzipan muffins machen und
danach dekorieren wir sie mit schönen
rosen und ich zeige euch heute einfach
ganz kurz und ganz schnell wie man
richtig tolle rosen ausmaß paar machen
kann und ich zeige euch einfach mal kurz
die zutaten
ich habe hier 50 gramm zimmer waren
butter 50 gramm zucker 100 gramm
marzipanrohmasse ich habe das lübecker
marzipan und ich hab das jetzt hier so
ganz einfach gelesen und zwar mit seiner
reise einfach gehalten und durch geräten
einfach damit ich später gleich mit in
den teig geben kann und sich das mit dem
teig verbindet dann brauche ich zwei
eier eine prise salz 200 gramm mehl eine
fliese backpulver 1 teelöffel backpulver
natürlich und hier habe ich noch 50
gramm mandeln und damit dies doch
richtig lecker wird kommen da noch
sauerkirschen rhein und die müssen wir
jetzt gleich erst mal noch ab
dafür nehme ich es einfach sondern sie
und jetzt die sich etwas die kirschen ab
und fangen aber das wasser auf was ihr
den saft stehen kann man erstens mal
trinken heu und zweitens benutzt meinte
so ein bisschen für den teig ich lasse
jetzt einfach hier noch ein bisschen
abtropfen und wer sich schon mal den
teig zubereiten
dafür gebe ich jetzt zuerst die weiche
butter in die schüssel rein dann kommt
der zucker mit dazu vom endlichen
genau jetzt lassen wir das einfach eine
minute lang früher
jetzt kommt da noch das marzipan mit
dazu das bietet auch ganz gut eingerührt
und jetzt gehen nach die eier mit
jetzt fehlt noch die prise salz und die
restlichen trockenen zutaten und der
frühere ich mir kurz mehl mit backpulver
und faktoren jetzt nicht kommt dann
kommt es mir auch mit dazu dann auch die
mangel
und jetzt kommt noch einen schluck vom
kirschwasser von vier schafft mit dazu
und jetzt wird es nur ganz kurz ein
gerührt
jetzt nämlich noch die kirche lasse noch
mal kurz abtropfen und gebt mir einfach
mit in den teig und hebst du dann unter
ist nämlich einfach nation ihre stelle
ich mir das ist im teig ab und gibt es
einfach immer machen gleich
ich habe jetzt die machen formen gefüllt
und werde die machen sind packen und
zwar beim 105 unseren ober unterhitze
für ungefähr 15 bis 20 minuten
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen zeit
übrig es kommt einfach vorbei an wie
groß oder machen frauen sind und ich
sage euch einfach kleinsten
ich werde schon meine marzipan rosen
herstellen und ich bin jetzt dafür hier
dieses marzipan und zwar ist ssd komatsu
waren einmal ein boden einmal in grün
und es bekommt man einfach auch in jedem
supermarkt also einzig in der buck
abteilung und ich nehme das jetzt
einfach und da gibts da hinten drauf
eine anleitung den harmlosen cyber
herstellen kann
da gibt es einfach ganz verschiedene
möglichkeiten august fertigstellen und
heute zeigt ist die möglichkeit mit dem
markt das ist einfach unser folie drin
das muss man aufschneiden hatte ich ja
auch schon jetzt kann ich hier etwas im
schnitt nehmen dass ich auch echt selber
ich richtig schön also nicht zu weich
aber oder trash ganz gleich
weiterverarbeiten und dann rolle ich da
einfach mit dem ausland statt drüber ich
habe übrigens meine seele flotte einfach
umgedreht damit ich eine weise
unterlagen seien also sehen wird aber
zur stunde mathe mit zu kennzeichnungen
und
weiter ich habe jetzt nicht sehr dünn
also das sind es ungefähr drei bis vier
millimeter nehme ich mir einfach was zum
ausstellte nichts zu einer spritztour
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch ein
deckel von der flasche oder sowas nehmen
oder in kleinen runden ausstecher und da
stehe ich mir zur kleine kreise aus fünf
stück brauche ich jetzt für eine hose so
den rechtsklick jetzt zusammen und nehme
mir jetzt ein kleines stückchen hier und
es vor mich jetzt zu einem kegel und ist
jetzt die basis meiner hose jetzt
brauche ich ein bisschen
frischhaltefolie und legt er jetzt immer
so ein rosenblatt rein
besser könnte es ganze jetzt auch
zwischen zwei silikon marten machen aber
ich möchte einfach dass ihr seht was ich
jetzt mache das nehme ich einfach den
finger und streiche so eine hälfte des
platzes flacht und es um und kam einfach
dick bleiben flach streifen
dann ist es oben das börsenblatt richtig
schön gibt es nämlich das erste und
schlägt mir das so um eine basis und
jetzt nehme ich einfach noch die andere
und streicht die ebenfalls vor
jetzt lege ich hier die rosenblätter
einfach außen rum und bevor ich jetzt
ist eine komplett verschließen
kommt schon wieder das nächste dran
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach noch das
grün und rollt es auch aus und wenn es
ab und zu ein bisschen leben sollte
nehmt euch einfach ein bisschen futter
zu kommen
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach so eine
struktur rolle und rotter heimat über
dann bekommt nämlich die marzipan denke
ich mir den ruhigen ausstecher könnte
aber auch zum beispiel ein trinkglas
nehmen soll einfach gleich auf dem
martin drauf passen die speziell aus ich
mir einfach noch so zwei ausstecher
einmal so ein blatt und ein mal eben für
den ansatz für die rose und steche ich
jetzt mit dem restlichen prima aus und
können gleich meine rose fertigte
probieren
wahrscheinlich einfach diese kleine
marzipan decke über den muffin legen und
mit hilfe eines werkzeugs könnte das ein
bisschen anpassen damit er komplett
verschlossen wird und das ist auch der
grund wieso ich eben tag wirklich sehr
wenig zucker hat danny marzipan decke
die kann man dann gleich komplett mit
essen und dann ist der muffin an sich
einfach nicht zu fühlen da kommen jetzt
noch die zwei blätter eine ganze ein
bisschen strukturieren formen und dann
kommt da noch unsere kurse
ihr könnt die blätter auch vorher etwas
mit grüner lebensmittelfarbe aus mit
seinem bruder abfordern
denn dann werden sie etwas dunkler und
diese dann einfach dann sieht man
einfach den unterschied zwischen
blättern und unterkunft
zu sehen ist die fertigen muffins aus
jetzt kann es natürlich passieren dass
wir sie transportieren wollte ja genau
diese hübsch jetzt ganz natürlich
passieren dass ihr euch runter fällt
bahntransport deswegen habe ich mir
jetzt einfach hier in den zahnstocher
halbiert steckt den innereien und steckt
eine große traum müsste einfach dann den
leuten sagen die das essen das ich mich
einfach einweisen und empfang und haben
sonst vorher entfernen
und jetzt ist diese machen vom allein
natürlich hübsch genug denn also muffin
förmchen ist eben immer so dass man hier
den rand zu unstet könnt ihr euch zb für
diese muffin förmchen nehmen und zwar
sind die bereits aus gespeist die kammer
einen zu kaufen und dann kann man die
hier einmal zusammen suchen dann stelle
ich das hin und stellen meinen ruf mache
ich wohl werk meine machen
gerade jetzt zeigen sich einfach noch
einen machen und ins ausland sieht sich
immer schön aus aber geblieben wie er
aussieht
natürlich wer schmidt ich habe eben
schon probiert also das ist ein richtig
schöner saftiger macht nicht so locker
leichter aber das war eine ganz schöne
dekoration pd wie ihr marzipan
rosenmachen sind und vor allen dingen
wie ihr leckere muffins backen können
und ich finde es richtig schnell gemacht
schmeckt sec und und verhandlungen sieht
sehr gut aus
und jetzt habe ich noch eine kleine
ankündigung und zwar kennt ihr
vielleicht die kate world messe das ist
die größte torten und kuchen messe
deutschlands und österreichs
und da gibt es in diesem jahr vier
termine und ich werde auf allen vier
messen seien mit einem eigenen stand und
dort dürft ihr mich alle besuchen
ich werde euch allerdings einfach deren
information in einem anderen video
bekannt geben
ich schreib ich aber schon die termine
und die standorte einfach unter meinem
video interview infobox könnt ihr
einfach mal schauen ob wir dahin kommen
wollt wir werden auch karten bei uns im
shop vor verkaufen und dann können wir
uns doch alle treffen
und dieses rezept gibt es jetzt zum
nachlesen auf meinem blog auf gab es
genau und da gibt es das rezept zum
nachlesen
ich würde euch wollen wir nicht die maße
von rosen mal ausprobiert und auch die
maße panda fans und wird mich freuen
wenn ich an feedback auf facebook oder
instagram bekommen oder auch auf youtube
bis zum nächsten mal